it's getting very interesting without a
doubt a deep state reckoning it's
happening before our very eyes
the single biggest abuse of power
scandal in American history is about to
be laid bare for all to see
sources tonight are confirming to me
that things are most likely even worse
than we originally thought we have that
new letter from the assistant attorney
general Stephen Boyd revealing that the
do J's investigations into the origins
of the Russia probe is broad in scope it
is multifaceted and that's not all
according to Boyd the investigation will
cover quote activities of US and foreign
intelligence services as well as
non-governmental organizations and
individuals now here's what likely this
whole means the Attorney General along
with US Attorney John Durham they are
now investigating how foreign spy
agencies allies of the United States
were used likely by Obama
administration's top officials in the
Intel community to spy on Trump in the
Trump campaign and adda Trump transition
team and the Trump presidency in other
words to explain this this investigation
is now examining how high ranking in
telefilms literally were outsourcing
what is politically motivated dirty work
to spy agencies in friendly countries
clearly to circumvent American laws and
the Civil Liberties of the American
citizens and used in an effort to rig a
presidential election that is now how
deep this possibly goes that would mean
people like Comey and Brennan and
clapper
may want to pay close attention because
this is not looking good for any of them
at this hour we now know the Attorney
General has requested that America's
intelligence agencies use these three
specific things one preserve all
relevant records to ensure the
availability of witnesses that may be
pertinent to the review three begin
identifying and assembling all materials
that may be relevant to this full
comprehensive review and there's more in
this very same letter the assistant AG
Stephen Boyd is outlining that the
investigation is quote a collaborative
ongoing effort between the department's
review team and the intelligence
community as well as foreign actors
like we were just talking about one such
foreign actor we all know about as
Christopher Steele he's set to be
interviewed by American investigators in
coming days and as you know by now
Steele was the former spy foreign spy
mi6 paid by Hillary Clinton paid by the
DNC even paid by the FBI at one point to
create that dirty Russian dossier the
one that Oh even the New York Times says
was likely Russian disinformation from
the beginning we certainly know it was
full of lies misinformation and
propaganda and by the way he says
himself Christopher steel has no idea if
any of this is true
none whatsoever in an interrogatory in
Great Britain but this is the same
unverifiable information that even its
own author won't confirm that in fact
was used by James Comey the FBI director
at the time to secure the first FISA
warrant in October of 2016 against not
only Trump campaign associate Carter
page but it opened a backdoor to spy on
the entire Trump campaign than the
entire Trump transition team then the
entire Trump White House when he became
president so let's be clear 99.9% of
American intelligence officers workers
in this country they perform dangerous
and courageous work they use the best
skills in the industry the surveillance
tools to keep Americans safe from
terrorism hostile actors at home and
abroad but in the height of the 2016
election just a few select high-ranking
bad actors they abused all of these
powerful tools of intelligence that we
entrust to them and it's clear tonight
they trampled on the rights of many
Americans they committed what is clearly
a premeditated fraud on FISA Court
judges to illegally obtain warrants with
information they knew was false and by
the way they withheld that from the
judges
and they used their top secret access as
a backdoor into the communications in
the Trump campaign from transition and
even the Trump presidency
remember Watergate was nothing but a
bungled burglary these actions represent
what would be a clear present danger to
our constitutional republic these tools
of an
telogen are so powerful it's that
serious and that's not all they used
undercover informants to spy on multiple
Trump campaign officials and yet another
attempt to spy on team Trump they spread
Christopher Steele's Russian lies
throughout the federal government
they even leaked it to the press to
influence the 2016 election and yes it
looks like they used foreign
intelligence agencies to spy on American
citizens so they can circumvent the
American Constitution and American laws
and those associated they were going
after with Donald Trump sadly what I've
just outlined is likely just the tip of
the iceberg
this is dangerous this is criminal
conduct from top officials in the US
government and the Biden Obama
government now in coming weeks months
Bar dorm they will conduct as they say a
broad investigation we will get the
answers make no mistake we will get
justice on this program we take
government accountability and the
powerful tools of intelligence that are
designed to protect us not be abused we
take it all seriously however that's not
the case among Democrats on the hill we
saw this on display yesterday Jerry
Nadler dusting off the cobwebs and the
moth balls on a felon no liar who
obstructed justice John everything every
Republicans worse than Watergate Dean so
he could compare Trump to Richard Nixon
in front of the House Judiciary
Committee oh just like he compared
George W Bush to Nixon also that
embarrassing political circus and stunts
is just one small part of the Democrats
plan to smear slander besmirch president
Trump around every turn for them this is
all about politics 2020 instead of
actually passing laws serving the
American people making a safe and secure
or more prosperous this is where their
focus is Democrats are now attempting to
investigate Believe It or Not the Russia
hoax for yet a fifth time and today they
move forward with a plan they want to
now go after the AG and former White
House cancelled counsel Don McGann in
contempt and hold them in contempt for
refusing to participate in their sham
hearings and meanwhile congressman
Cummings he's planning to hold more sham
hearings Barr and Commerce Secretary
Wilbur Ross in contempt for not turning
over documents related to the US census
of all things and as per usual Democrats
are abusing their power to turn the
government into a weapon against
political opponents we'll have a lot
more on that in a moment but first we do
turn to our 2020 campaign trail watch
where a sleepy creepy crazy Uncle Joe
Biden made several rare appearances
today in Iowa and the so-called
Democratic frontrunner first event
attracted a whopping well less than 200
people and that's on the high side 200
that's it this was a speech heavily
promoted by the his friends and the
media mob compare that to any Trump
rally compare that to the outside of the
Trump rally there is a massive
enthusiasm gap for crazy Uncle Joe and
probably for good reason
not only does Biden carry the weight of
this historically awful Oh Biden Obama
Biden track record but the vice
president former vice president doesn't
exactly inspire any voters today all
eighty-five at one rally attendees were
treated to a marie-anne during rambling
25-minute speech where a sleepy creepy
crazy Uncle Joe called President Trump
an existential threat to the country
such a powerful while statement by Uncle
Joe look I believe that the president is
literally an existential threat to
America he is a genuine threat to our
core values America was built in the way
we were built basic core values DCCC
honor leave it known behind realizing
that there are things that are bigger
than you in America that we have to get
together we have to cooperate
but this is a guy who does everything to
separate and frighten people it's about
fear and loathing Sleepy creepy crazy
Uncle Joe is apparently not happy the
President Trump well he continues to
question his competency for office all
we need do is look back at the eight
prior years when they were in office
yeah a disaster take a look I'd rather
run against I think Biden did anybody I
think he's the weakest mentally and I
like running against people that are
weak mentally I think Joe is the weakest
up here the other ones have much more
energy I don't agree with their policy
but I think Joe is a man who was I call
him 1% Joe because until Obama came
along he didn't do very well Joe Biden
thought that China was not a competitor
of us Joe Biden is a dummy Joe Biden
thought China was not a competitor China
made 500 billion dollars over a short
period of time against Obama Biden and
for many many years so after decades in
the Washington swap while crazy Joe
Biden is acquired well a ton of baggage
much like Hillary Clinton it could be
his downfall last night HBO's Bill Maher
actually admitted what we've been saying
that Hillary Clinton was a terrible
candidate and she also obstructed
justice all while of course taking a
shot at Trump but she did obstruct
justice and she did well commit felonies
take a look now there's a lot of reasons
why the Democrats lost and many of them
were Hillary was a terrible candidate
that's absolutely she didn't help the
situation with the emails in judging how
she handled those interactions
absolutely not right and she committed
obstruction of justice if not Trump did
I think in much worse fashion but you
know I mean smashing up your fault about
it was okay hat tip to Bill Maher he
actually told the truth a guy on the
Left told the straight on truth yeah go
ahead try it yourself see if you delete
subpoenaed emails acid-wash the hard
drive and busted up devices and remove
SIM cards after this subpoenaed good
luck to you